boom we're here coronavirus and all yeah
the streets of San Francisco are empty
you could have walked down in the middle
of street and would've been fine yeah
and we're in this studio and Sam's just
coughing up a storm which is got me
concerned salaries this may be my last
podcast you don't know catch and kill
you so this is for all the students of
Stanford Harvard Syracuse that have been
shut down there at home certainly just
listening to the podcast in quarantine
this is for you this one goes out to you
yeah good luck all right what I want to
talk about we got a bunch of words on
the screen they all look interesting
where do you wanna start pick one can we
talk about I want to do things before we
jump in
yeah are we doing a plug of Jordan
Harbinger podcast yeah but I think we
want to talk to him about it right like
we want him to be talking to us as the
plug okay so we're gonna be promoting
his podcasts and he will be doing it to
us yeah scratch our back we scratch his
back right so if you hear a plug from
him going listen to his podcast he's
actually helping us a ton and the second
thing is I read every review for the
podcast we have 600 reviews maybe 794
just check this more seven 800 800
they're all five stars except for like
five yeah and that's cool I like reading
the positive reviews and those five were
from early on when you weren't even on
the pod so really I take those I take
those out no they were 2.5 stars and I
like listening to negative feedback and
I don't like following all of it but
some of it the first was that the sound
for the guests were bad a Greek fare we
will listen to that in the second one
and I hate this I don't hate it in that
it bothers me but I just don't like I
don't think it's bad feedback which is
we were called Bros right and I don't
really care about that because what's
that mean how is that supposed to be
like people use that as an insult I
don't understand why that's an insult
yeah it's an insult for sure to be clear
it used to not be an insult but being
called a bro is an insult and yeah I
don't know is it the way we talk is what
we talk about is it or we using the
wrong words I'm not
exactly sure yeah I don't take offense
to that even though people mean it to be
offensive so I don't care if people say
that yeah I'm not a bro I'm a lover not
a fighter you know I I got multiple
angles
I got gear what does the pro mean I
don't know Henry what's a bro
we need the gig you gotta go into the
mic come on bro maybe we have to replace
Henry with a female and then we'll get
more credit for not being just a bro
down no I don't care about being called
a bro so then it's a compliment yeah
kind of I don't know whatever I'm not
gonna be liked I'm just trying to be me
no well here's what I'm trying to do I'm
trying to be B and I'm trying to create
stuff that people want and if
predominantly people think it's brony
but they love it I'm okay with that
yeah like for example I listen to the
gel Rogan podcast Joe Rogan talks about
his Carnivale call meat diet you know
working out UFC fighting cage fighting
hunting you know these are the cars like
these are his topics because that's what
he's genuinely interested in I like
talks about it talks about other things
to everything else and I like would
people I like listening to stuff where
people are interesting and they're
interested in certain stuff and so for
me the test with this podcast is what I
want to listen to this and so the
episode I just sort of think would I be
interested listen to that podcast and if
it's appealing to me that I'm sure it's
appealing to other people it's not gonna
be appealing to everybody for sure and
then the last bit of negative feedback
we got which is we focus too much on the
San Francisco Silicon Valley scene and
I'm from Missouri
by way of Tennessee you're from
everywhere including Colorado I love San
Francisco and I hate it at the same time
I'll be the first to make fun of it but
also I love all types of cool [__] going
on throughout the country so yeah that's
probably fair it's interesting let's
talk about it in fact I actually think
personally I think we skew a little too
far in the kind of like low tech ideas
and I think there's a lot of interesting
high tech ideas that don't require a
high tech entrepreneur for example I
don't know how to code but I've started
to that tech startups in Silicon Valley
taking venture capital money and
worked with an engineering team where
I'm the only guy in the room who doesn't
know anything about engineering you can
do that so I actually think that there's
plenty of cool stuff that we're not
talking about that I'm gonna be bringing
more of so if you don't like the Silicon
Valley stuff I'm sorry I'm gonna try to
bring more interesting technology to the
table because there's a lot of it out
there I feel like we haven't been
talking about it as much the way that I
describe San Francisco and Silicon
Valley is to me it's kind of like
Hollywood but it's only only if you're
trying to make like a like a big
blockbuster hit right um I believe that
you can make those anywhere it might be
a little bit more helpful if you are
physically in Hollywood because you not
because the chances are necessarily
higher but because you'll be around
other people who have similar once and
dreams and your baseline becomes a
certain thing for sure but you can
certainly make it from anywhere
absolutely it's been proven all right
let's talk about some of these things um
let's start with I'll start with the
Sequoia memo okay did you read this
no I avoided it on purpose Thanks denial
the best the best approach yeah I we
haven't raised venture capital so it's a
little bit different so Sequoia is one
of the biggest venture capital firms
here in Silicon Valley they are famous
for back in 2008 I want to say they
released this presentation called our IP
good times and they basically they
called an emergency meeting of all their
portfolio companies they invited them to
this dinner locked him in a room put
this presentation up on the screen that
was basically like hey the good times
we've all been experiencing are about to
end here's why most of you entrepreneurs
you have not been a part of these cycles
we've been investors through the dot-com
boom and the bust and then this new boom
and this was right before the sort of
financial crisis of 2008 and they told
them look money is about to become hard
to come by we are going to have a giant
financial crisis it will have ripple
down effects to you guys to your
customers to your clients to your
investors and so you need to start
tightening up anything you're wasting
money on you need to stop wasting it
anything if you haven't raised money if
you don't have twelve months in the bank
you need to go raise money right now to
sort of be able to endure a downturn and
they just released another one
which is the new Sequoia memo so that
was 2008 now they released a new one and
they basically like look this
coronavirus stuff is a this is a once in
a hundred year virus and there's this
it's happened in China which is like
when you shocked China you shocked the
global supply chain and also now that
travel is gonna stop a whole bunch of
business is gonna come to a halt that
stock markets gonna go into a panic
because we've been in a ten-year bull
run and that's about to sort of end
anyways so they told them the same thing
change your spending habits you need to
tighten up raise money if you if you
have an offer out there take it don't
worry about valuation just take and get
the money in the bank and and you know
you need to go into a sort of survival
mode you need to change gears and that's
what just came out which i think is very
interesting
have you made any adjustments to your
business not yet but I live like this
anyway I'm kind of a cockroach in the
first place yeah and I actually think
that me living this way has kind of been
a consequence it has been is hurt me
more than it's helped me actually I
think it made it so I wouldn't spend
enough money which if you have a machine
that turns a dollar into more than one
dollar dump that dump the truck your
money truck like what ad spend or what
do you mean yeah I mean look if you have
a funnel where you are a product where
if you just spend more on marketing or
spend more on engineers or spend more on
content creators and it turns that new
customer into more than what you
acquired them for right then if anyone
had a little machine that turned one
dollar into one dollar one penny the
name of the game is throw as much money
on into that machine as you possibly can
as fast as you can and I've had those
machines and I didn't capitalize on it
and so I've lived this way all the time
and I think it actually hurt me a lot
but in times like these bring it on
yeah you don't need to adjust we haven't
changed how we've done things just
because we're always tight yeah and your
company's in a good position to like
just now before this we were looking at
a company's P&L and it was like cash in
the bank 220 grand or something like
that psyche - sure a couple months away
from insolvency you know if that is the
case whereas you guys are in a much
better position yes I do I am I do have
a little fear I don't know how I feel
about this Corona thing when it means
what it means for business I do
think that I'm on the side of I think
it's bad but I don't think it will be as
bad as I think
or as I originally thought right I I
guess I just have faith I have a lot of
blind faith that it will work out which
so I've been on the other side of the so
so when we were doing our idea lab I
work to this guy Michael birch Michael
birch was is known as if you just google
he's like one of the top growth guys in
the world he sort of was doing an
invented viral marketing before viral
marketing was a word he did it because
he didn't have money back in the day so
he built one of the first address book
importers where for this company called
birthday alarm he had he was like and I
think he did it before that at a Marinis
company I forget what that was called
Birkin was before that so so Berthillon
was the first one where he was like hey
I want people to send this to their
friends what if I just imported all the
addresses from their hotmail and then I
made it easy push this button to send it
and he's like he literally told me at
his house he was like I thought that ten
days later like I thought there's no way
they let this go for more than ten days
and he's like it's now been 15 years and
this thing still works and he's like so
he was working on viral marketing cuz he
just didn't have a budget so he's like I
gotta use my customers to get me more
customers and to explain it you didn't
explain it totally clear but someone
signs up for your thing it says do you
want to invite your friends here's your
gmail contacts click select all and send
an email to all of them and so in this
case for birthday alarm it was I make a
calendar where I'm Alan vite you I'll
say hey say I'm can you add your
birthday to my calendar I don't want to
forget your birthday this is before
Facebook cases by the way and so you
would add your birthday to my calendar
and they would haste and say hey Sam
don't you want to remember Shawn's
birthday that'd be nice like reciprocate
and you be like yeah sure and then it
would say hey Sam you've got one
birthday on the calendar but you surely
got more friends than one so why don't
you invite some other friends here let
me make it easy for you would you like
to import all your friends from hotmail
and you're like yes and then and he
added one thing at a time to make it
more viral so he would add a prefilled
message he's like oh there people are
stopping because they can't think of
what to say right so here's a pre filled
message that I know works and then I
just say sent and so then he got this
thing super viral so you know birthday
alarm grew to 50 million members with
zero paid marketing 50 million and
and then he's done this again and again
since then with his social network Bebo
and others so when I worked with them
the name of the game was viral growth
and so we did a charity campaign they're
trying to raise money for charity water
well we made a story a website that was
just telling a story of this boy jean
bosco with no water and then we said can
we get this to go viral so we did the
same thing import import emails get
people to send the story to their
friends and raise money for the cause
and we got it to go viral so I've
literally been Bennett we're like
nothing nothing nothing you'd come into
work nothing no growth no growth no
growth and you would just tweak the
right thing and then all of a sudden
that you know between overnight
something would have doubled and the
next morning it doubled again next
morning double began and I remember it's
just going from zero to five million
people signing up for this charity thing
within like you know two weeks it was
insane and so I've seen viral growth and
how counterintuitive it is like you
don't think you know well yesterday we
had 4,000 people so today we're gonna
have I don't know 5,000 6,000 it's like
no you're gonna have 16,000 then you
have 32,000 and it's gonna you know it's
gonna go up to the millions within a few
days and so I've seen viral growth when
you're talking about in the good sense
from a product perspective now it's
viral growth of an actual [__] virus
and so and it you could see actually in
the u.s. somebody did a great graph
where they mapped Italy where everything
is on lockdown because Italy is started
spreading like crazy and they showed
Italy day one us day one Italy day two
the u.s. day two number of cases and the
bar graphs are like identical and the
thing is we're just in like whatever day
six and you can see by day 21 where this
thing gets to if you don't like lock
everything down right away so I am very
fearful because I've seen viral growth
I've seen viral spread and I know that
it doesn't work the way it breaks our
brains our brains think things go
linearly but this goes exponentially and
it's really hard to just comprehend an
exponential spread and to take the story
a different way than coronavirus which
is that stuff that you're describing
that Michael purchasing you can actually
still get all these two cool plugins
that auto automatically like allow
people to share a pre-populated message
to all their gmail contacts we use it
and people still share yeah and the math
works out where you know
because you would think I would never do
that wouldn't email all my content we
had a lot of people doing it but people
do it and what happens is you know 1% or
less will do it but you look at the map
1% of people do it on an average they
have 326 contacts so for every hundred
people that come in you get three
hundred twenty six people blasted out it
doesn't work as good as that time
because the email open rates are much
higher than yeah but now people are like
oh I don't know I never talked to Sam so
if he's sending me this this is junk
this is spam
now people filter it but in certain
countries it works like we were growing
like we could do this like clockwork in
India in India people still open it like
they did in the US ten years ago and
they forward even higher rates I don't
care look forward everything and
everybody and so India Turkey all these
little countries where we would see this
crazy growth that you couldn't get in
the US and or UK anymore they kind of
suck because the monetary value and you
know the value per user is lower there
but it does still feel good to get like
it really works and people are shocked
by that yeah we did one through SMS I
remember and over the weekend it went
viral and like you know during the week
Monday through Friday everything looked
fine is growing but like not at a crazy
pace we didn't realize the viral
coefficient was two and so over the
weekend it took off and started
compounding on a big number and we
racked up a hundred twenty thousand an
SMS a hundred forty thousand dollar bill
and SMS is going through Kazakhstan it's
like we don't even know we're growing
we're gonna grow in Kazakhstan and it
went crazy and turns out texting in
Kazakhstan is super expensive and so one
hundred twenty thousand dollars in two
days we had to pay off that's crazy
sucked the texting stuff which we
haven't you want talked about supper
mm-hmm
okay you want to scroll up for me or
whatever okay okay
supper I I think it's supper comm what
did they just raised was it forty
million dollars today and a four hundred
million dollar valuation total they've
raised a hundred fifty million dollars
in valuation it's a cool that's a cool
service if you're a consumer how does
work yeah so you want to reuse supper if
you're trying to find an apartment
you'll probably run in December cuz
you're like it's a search engine to find
apartments to rent
yeah and typically for these new guys
San Francisco isn't the major market
it's typically more middle more
where they have high-rise buildings
which we don't have a lot here but
basically if you google Chicago
apartments or moving to Chicago or
something like that jumper or apartment
list mile the place where I used to work
or a bunch of other things like that
will come up and I'll be like here's 843
apartments available in Chicago click
here to get information and submit your
information ok great
here's how they work which a lot of
people have no idea how they work Henry
I'm gonna explain to you how they work
and you tell me if you ever heard this
okay so they're lead-gen companies you
know what a lead gen company is okay the
way it works is a lot of people are
shocked by this and it's actually way
easier to start that most people would
realize so the way it works is there's I
don't know how many there are who do
this but I know that there for sure four
or five that do this that are big names
and so just in the apartments but just
in the apartment space so there's
apartments com I believe there's rent
comm and there's maybe two others that
are quite large and then there's dozens
that you don't even realize exists you'd
have to google them and find them but
what they do is they work with all the
big apartment buildings so there's gray
star which has probably millions of
apartments then there's co star which
has a bunch and then there's every
apartment building that you have world
star race star and then there's a Avalon
Avalon Bay I think they're called
there's a bunch of them and they have
millions of units in what they do is
they go to red calm and they go or
apartments calm and they go for every
person who signs a lease with us or who
calls our our phone we're gonna give you
a hundred bucks
and so what supper can do or probably
how they started out or what anyone can
do is they go hey Apartments calm you
guys are getting a hundred dollars per
call will you give us ten dollars per
email we give you of people who are
qualified leads
so what supper did I mentioned they
didn't when they launched and I'll
explain why I say when they launched is
what they did was they go these places
and they go alright give us a cut of the
revenue per email and so the math works
out that if we send you five emails
basically people who said here's my
email address here's my phone number
I'm interested in a two-bedroom at this
particular building apartments will will
be like alright we'll give you $10 for
that because we're pretty confident that
for every five of these we collect one
of them
become a lead and so now we make fifty
bucks in profit and so what supper does
is they create a different funnel where
they learn how to rank really high on
moving to Chicago find an apartment or
they are able to have really good
facebook ads and they get all these
leads and that's what their margin is
and so the Martin margins for these
businesses I know this first hand could
be 60 to 70 percent gross margin which
means let's see what's the math behind
that you million bucks comes through the
door you paid you know two hundred fifty
K on search engine marketing yeah but
you know the rest is because there's no
cogs there's no there's no physical
product you're selling so you have a
very high margin product sixty-seven
percent margin plus whatever content
staff you have internally that's your
other cost so it's just a legion company
yeah and the interesting thing I've
known a lot of people who have these
lean lead gen companies I knew a guy who
had a legion company for swimming pools
so if you wanted to buy a swing swimming
pool you'd Google by swing pool
repairman or indoor ground pool indoor
in-ground pool setup California or
something like that he's number one he
would he would be number one you submit
your information and he would sell it to
these people who go in services actually
do the thing who actually do the work
you're a middleman when your elite now
there's pros and cons to this business
the first pro is you could set these up
really cheaply and you could start
making cash flow very quick like if you
were able to spend one month just
building the site and creating the
relationship with this person you could
next day go out and start making cash so
long as you were profitably acquire a
customer right so that's great the
second great thing is you could do this
for most anything the best way I think
to figure out how to do this is you
figure out what has the largest total
market size with also the largest
possible cost per lead with also the
least amount of competition and you do
like a grid yeah like a great and so for
example I've been bullish on truck
drivers the reason why is I think that
there's a whole lot of truck drivers in
America the average truck driver makes a
good salary let's say $50,000 a year
therefore recruiters would be willing to
pay like a hundred bucks per lead so I
was like can I send leads there or you
could do it for local services so I need
a
landscaper or I near need irrigation
work done at my house right my home and
someone will buy those leads for I don't
know fifty bucks so you can do this for
anything right
you just have to optimize for what so my
father-in-law's in the senior living
business he owns a couple of facilities
and the biggest thing for them his
business looks great when he has high
occupancy rates and it looks terrible if
he gets high vacancy so low occupancy
and so there's companies out there that
do this for seniors if you start
googling like you know you know memory
care and Alameda California there's a
company that will pop up right in the
top of search and say hey we've reviewed
the top 15 you know facilities here and
come read about them or hey are you
looking for this talk to our consultant
just put in your email address here and
we'll help you get land in a spot and so
then they'll pay these lead-gen services
a high amount because you know somebody
who goes into a senior senior facility
they're paying eight thousand dollars
per month and they're usually there till
end of life and so you get you know that
very high lifetime value of that
customer so you're willing to pay $1,000
per qualified leave who's looking in
your area
I don't know that exact number but high
price and I have first-hand knowledge I
know someone personally and I know the
financials of a senior home living or
senior living lead-gen business it made
hundreds of thousands of dollars a month
in revenue and a very good profit I know
someone who did it for rent to own
properties I know people who have done
it for like I said swimming pools I know
people who have done it for apartments I
know a guy who did it for local home
services and did about 60 to 70 million
dollars a year in sales right and so
that's the name of the game I also know
people have done it for jobs jobs is
another good one now like rigged up has
done this they've raised money at two or
three billion dollar valuation and
they've done it for oil workers and the
way the math works is there's actually
way more oil workers in America than you
think hundreds of thousands or can be
hundreds of thousands and those oil
workers the barrier to entry is
relatively low you don't have to have
like a master's degree in something so
anyone can do it or a lot of people can
do it and the salary is quite high a
hundred grand a year in some cases so
they're willing to spend a lot of money
and so it's a really interesting company
bit or a business rather and a lot of
people don't know that's how it works
now here's the downside
the downside is lead-gen companies can
be very transactional which means as a
business
you only capture value and make money
the more leads you're coming in through
there and often that means you only make
money when you're spending money a lot
of times u they suck at building brands
so like I said you could spend something
up really fast that means it can likely
go away just as fast because let's say
that um like if you create a URL that's
like home senior home living California
com that is not like maybe maybe someone
just going to google that and they're
gonna see it one time they don't think
you yeah and then they're gonna get
there and they're done they're never
gonna think about you ever again and you
have to pay for them again
and so if you want more customers you
got pay again right and so that's quite
hard so if you can build a brand around
it then that's where it's really
interesting and the second thing is that
you are dependent on the person buying
elite so in my case I worked for a
person who was doing Legion and they go
alright there's a cap on this like we
can only make a certain amount of money
giving leads the way that we become a
huge business is we get we make a
relationship directly with the apartment
buildings and go straight there go
straight to them now the reason why that
sucked is because the person buying the
liege is like oh you're our competition
now right you're out and they cut it off
and their revenue goes away immediately
right and so what thumbtack did I like
thumbtack what they've done is they've
built a direct relationship with the
people so if you Google San Francisco
wedding photographer and you see a
wedding photographer on thumbtack
they've built that relationship with
them and thumb and that wedding
photographer will pay thumbtack directly
for a lead that's great because there's
no middleman to cut out now the downside
with that is it costs a ton of money to
do this is like a really big total
marketplace and so you likely have to
raise money or figure out some scrappy
way to get it done right but that's my
rant on and the big version of these if
you take it to its absolute max it's
like Expedia or booking.com
yeah right so what they're doing is
they're saying okay cool you want to
book a flight I will become the best at
ranking for how to search for flights
find a good flight here's some
recommended trips and then we just the
airline's pay us a commission and
affiliate fee for every lead we're
sending them and that is a notoriously
difficult it yeah they've done well but
they're hyper competitive and they're
you know it's always contentious and
then hotels is another one that's quite
challenging if I wanted to make money
really fast I would
find a relatively boring one like
trucking jobs yes I find interesting but
most people do not so they want to enter
that the flights and travel is a lot
sexier and so it's hard give you another
niche one I have a friend who created
this business called a ply board and
what he was doing was international
students people I went to high school in
China and when I when I was graduating
in China everybody wanted to come to the
u.s. to study everyone wants to come to
u.s. colleges so internationally India
China Indonesia Malaysia the best
students all want to come to the US if
they can so they want to come to the US
but they don't know where the hell to
start they don't know what the schools
are they don't know how to apply they
don't know how to translate there they
are scoring on all these like you know
aptitude test in Malaysia to like what
the US schools want etc so there's a
barrier there and the US schools love
foreign students because they pay more
like I think a foreign student who
international student who's going to
school at Berkeley will pay double the
tuition as a local student not just to
in-state student like a u.s.
out-of-state student versus
international the International and
Allah knows you you pay double okay
great like nine times as much going to
school that's insane so basically what
he was doing so he went to colleges and
and you have all these small colleges
that just need applicants cuz they don't
have a brand name so yeah a lot of
Stanford and Harvard they don't really
care because they're getting so many
applicants anyways doesn't matter but
like San Jose State you know they were
like hey we will pay you $1,000 per
admitted student $3,000 per admitted
student so he was getting three grand
per admission in contract with all these
different schools and then he just had
to do lead gen on the other side for
students who want to go to school in
America which was actually a big market
of people who are searching for what
happened to it I still go in I don't
know I haven't checked in with him
lately but hope you're doing good
Martin I hope you're doing alright
International yeah I went to University
of Sydney as well it was it was crazy we
started I we should actually talk about
that on another time because that's an
interesting thing there but to get back
to this Lee thing to wrap this up
there's actually a lot and this is way
bigger than people think and one of the
biggest ones is credit cards Credit
Karma I don't know what they do in
revenue but they just sold for a billion
dollars I but they did wonder I bet they
did a billion in sales and what their
hook was we're gonna get you to sign up
for a report I credit a free credit
report and we're gonna recommend credit
cards for you use and they'll make $100
per credit card affiliate we get you
they get
now think about credit cards huge market
huge referral fees very competitive nerd
wallet does the same thing they're the
bootstrap I think I don't know multi
hundred millionaire yeah I mean but I
think they bootstrap to like 50 or 60
million in sales then raised money so
it's quite good
now here's another company here's one
more interesting thing you know the
penny hoarder no I don't actually I
don't wanna go through the penny hoarder
the penny hoarder calm Kyle spoke at
hustle con he's a cool guy
he he's was a great success story still
is but he started the penny holder and
what it did was he would write about
when he was poor he didn't have any
money he would say I didn't have any
money I was I was trying to pay my bills
and so I would do things like drive uber
or I would do coupon clipping and he
would blog about it and anytime someone
saw an article that he wrote about
driving for uber he would make 2 grand
per driver and so he was like oh this is
cool watch I'm gonna blog about all the
ways in which I can save money or make
extra money and so he did that like
through like there's websites where you
can fill out surveys and make dollars I
make a few bucks and he would talk about
it and mostly middle America moms would
see and be like that's great I'll make
money on the side and I'll sign up and
he would get an affiliate fee and he
scaled this thing from zero to sixty
million in sales completely bootstrapped
in like six years I love this and here's
the problem there's this other company
called fluent media fluent I think it's
called fluent fluent is a publicly
traded company and they are performance
marketers which means they
when I'm describing but across tons of
niches so someone will say like DirecTV
will come to them and be like hey I'll
give you $80 for every customer you sent
us and they go great and they spin up
these landing pages and fluent media
does this with trucking as well they do
a bunch of stuff if it's a big business
publicly traded they saw Kyle's website
and how much he was killing it cuz he
talked about it a lot for PR which I
mean it's good and bad good and bad and
they just and they they ripped him off
completely
they created like the dollar saver or
like something like very similar like
the penny holder they just copy the
website copied the articles and then
they threw it on Facebook and they drove
traffic to an article that said here are
the hundred best ways to save money and
they did the math too they could get a
click for a penny or they could get a
click for a dime and each person who
came they would make 20 cents because
that's the conversion rate of which I
believe it up and so Kyle at penny hodor
this is all public you can google it
sued them and what they found out was
fluent media according to the lawsuit
hired one of the penny hoarders
employees and they said yeah here's how
we did it and so they just spun this up
and it made a ton of money right off the
bat
yeah and so these are the pros and did
you win the suit I think it's ongoing
it's ongoing but uh for Kyle but this is
why this is interesting because I and
the penny holder amongst its crew a much
its audience I think has a great brand
and yeah a nerd wall actually at this
point has a great brain at first nerd
Walt was simply a you're just gonna
Google are just gonna Google best credit
card and we're gonna show up one and
you're not never gonna remember us but
at this point they're doing all this
advertising and commercials and people
like turn to the Nerds like it's working
that's a commercial so really
interesting business model I like Lee
Jen but a lot of people didn't realize
how that worked
Henry was that interesting did you learn
how it worked all right I got another
one for you
Manziel so this is cool this is one of
my favorite reasons to do the podcast is
that interesting people just reach out
and tell me about their business so
Manziel is this so this guy Sam reached
out he listens the podcast what's his
last name and so he was like hey I got
this business you know would love some
help with it
or just would love to chat and so I said
okay let's chat so get on the phone and
I end up blown away by what these guys
are doing so they teach me about
something I've never heard of and is now
very finite very very fascinating to me
so what they do is manzil does Islamic
financing what's that mean yeah we
talked about not on the podcast but we
talked about it offline cuz I was pretty
interested in it so Henry do you know
what Islamic financing is if you didn't
know Legion I don't think you'll go this
one so are you Muslim I'm not I'm Hindu
well I'm neither but like my my family
is Hindu so I didn't know about this but
basically in the Muslim faith there's
actually a sort of the advice is against
traditional loans so interest which is
known as like RIBA I think in the in in
their faith is frowned upon in these so
a traditional mortgage where you go to
the bank you have your down payment you
take out a loan and you're paying
interest is actually not compliant with
with their with their faith in their law
and which is actually common and a lot
of other different religions is that
true yeah so I'm Catholic Christian and
was raised that way and there's
definitely rules regarding handling
money and interests and things like that
yeah and I think the the fundamental
basis I'm going to kind of butcher this
so I apologize but I'm just trying to
explain as best as I understand it so so
apparently your money you sort of fiat
currency which is just not pegged in
anything it's just a made-up concept the
the belief system is that money has no
value inherent value in itself and so
you should not be charged interest for
borrowing money which is this sort of
abstract concept so they have loans or
they have sort of agreements which can
work as long as both sides are taking
shared risk and getting sort of shared
shared upside shared return in some way
so there's damn Islamic I believe so
yeah and his partner Mohammed is also so
they were explaining to me that hey
there's this big thing called economic
financing and there's these like
challenger banks and so if you ever
heard the word challenger Bank check
this out it's pretty pretty cool
we know that banking is been around for
these big Bank brands that are you know
in every country there's there's big
banks that are worth billions of dollars
and recently over the last let's say
five to seven years there's these things
called challenger banks or neo banks
they're called
and so in Brazil there's a bank called
new bank and you bank and brand new bank
is worth 10 billion dollars it's one of
those valuable startups in Brazil in the
UK there's challenger banks oh my god
I'm gonna forget this challenger just
means a new one it's a start-up bank
yeah and they're they offer different
things so what these guys did was better
digital access so mobile apps quicker
ability to get sort of credit cards and
debit cards spun up and so there's you
know there's a couple of them that are
huge now a few different multi-billion
dollar startups done this well these
guys have done is they've done this for
a faith-based bank which is basically
saying there is a set of customers out
there in this case Muslims who are not
being served well by the generic banks
and we can make a bank that serves them
better and the way we're gonna do it is
you want to take a mortgage out you can
either take a sort of mortgage out
traditional mortgage which is not
compliant or you can take one out that's
compliant with your faith we've come up
with a mechanism that is blessed by sort
of the the village elders you know
they're sort of leaders in the community
that says yes this is you know I think
sharni allows what's called seeing its
compliant with sharni law and then on
the other side this is this will this
works as a mortgage you can actually buy
your home and so these guys have this
have this concept and in other countries
this is apparently really big so in
Africa Indonesia places where the Muslim
population is the dominant population
they've already solved this problem but
in places like US Canada where it's just
a minority of the population is is
Muslim they don't have these banks yet
so I love this startup idea because how
are they doing
so how they're doing so they're they
spent a lot of time making sure that
they can actually get it to be compliant
and actually get the financial mechanism
to work that took a while over a year
maybe two years now they've gotten that
to work and they have basically they
have two sides of a marketplace on one
side they have people who are investors
because you know if you're gonna issue
mortgages their average mortgages like
$500,000 so it takes a lot of capital to
start this business they don't want to
be the one didn't want to go raise a
billion dollars and then start issuing
these loans they want on one side to
have investors who
we'll put in the capital to fund these
loans and on the other side they want to
have the borrow ease who are trying to
buy a home who can pull from this pool
of you know sort of halal financing you
know this this financing that's
compliant and so they have ten million
dollars committed on the on the investor
side 1.2 million in their bank ten
million total and then and they're just
every week they're trying to close more
so I think which is a small amount but
this is like just inbound interest this
is not like they've never really done
anything yet but ten million will let
you let you do if you just do half a
million dollar loans that means they can
do whatever twenty mortgage is right now
and every mortgage has a certain value
so it's about worth about I don't know
20 K a year to them is that mortgage
just in their fee that they get on top
of it and so and on the other side they
have all these applicants I think you
know about a thousand applicants and
these are what they call super prime
applicants because these are people who
are doctors lawyers they have good jobs
they they have the money they have the
means to afford their homes they're just
looking for a solution that doesn't
force them to compromise their faith so
I really like this business little
there's a working model in the UK
there's a working model in in Africa
there's working model Indonesia there's
nothing in Canada where these guys are
and there's nothing really in the u.s.
where in America I think there's look
this up I think there's like a couple
million only to two million I want to
say roughly that's pretty interesting I
like that I think that there's a bunch
of weird rules around banking I mean
they're not weird they should be there
but and so starting a starting a bank I
think is it's so nearly impossible it's
very difficult so what all the Neo banks
do all the charter banks do not real
banks they're not real banks they sit on
top of BBVA or they sit on top of these
other banks and they're just the they're
the consumer-facing layer but the
banking happens with their underlying
partner and it's sort of like the lead
gen model that you're talking about they
go to these banks say hey I can get you
a whole bunch more customers I'm gonna
spend all the money during the marketing
they'll be banking with you but we own
this sort of relationship yeah and
that's actually pretty common I use this
thing my debit card is simple rightful
I've heard of it yeah
this is my debit card it's pretty cool I
like it because the customer service I
can just text and they're like you see
these like young
in Portland and they they're easy to
chat with and they answer 24 hours a day
they were acquired for a hundred million
dollars and I was like he's like a
freaking bank that's it yeah and I did
not a bank yeah and it was what's called
BBVA yeah that's who they use BBVA
Compass I think it's me exactly they're
under there's a few that are underneath
all these now the very first there's a
now one of the challenger banks got
their very first banking charter banking
license which is very rare if I forget
their name but they just announced a
couple weeks or last two weeks that sort
of so now it's very interesting now once
that seal broke because it was so hard
to apply for this yeah I think we and
they all want it Robin Hood wants their
license Breck's wants their license it's
just very hard for them to get I think
you need 5 / 10 percent in reserve yeah
you need a certain amount that's not
it's just that there's no incentive for
the government to give these out they're
like you you kind of highfalutin you
know tech startups do I really want to
give this to you
you've only been around for so long I
don't know if they I have the trust in
you so now the seals broken the first
one got it we'll see what what that
means but what I like about these guys
is they're not a bank they're not taking
your deposits they're just doing loan
issuance so on one side they have the
reserve cap they're their investment
fund but they're using other people's
money OPM on one side yeah other
people's money to make the loans and
they're the broker and they take one to
two percent of the transaction fee and
people are willing to pay a premium to
have halal financing just like people
willing to pay a premium for halal meat
or for vegan or kosher meat you know
whatever like right people are willing
to pay a premium for things that are
compliant with their faith I think this
could be big and you wants interesting I
think that they've had a hard time
raising money from traditional VCS
because this is understand hard to
understand yeah you have to like you
know most VCS are old white guys and you
know it's the sort of cliche and you
know I know they do look into it but I
think that there's now there's the
natural challenges of any high
aspiration startup they have those they
have the problems that any any started
but that's really ambitious but then
they also have the problem of like first
they need to educate you about this
problem like you saw how I stumbled
through this explanation and I talked to
these guys for an hour you know and
that's where I am after an hour of
really trying to understand it but you
and you read this by FERC on your best
so I ran her yeah I ran it by him I
introduced them yesterday I said hey
FERC on understands this he's Muslim
he's an
investor he's a technologist and he's an
entrepreneur if he doesn't like this I
don't like this see what did he say and
so he so he's like I've looked into this
she's like a lot of my friends really
wanted this I tried to look at what
options are available in the u.s. they
suck they're really super high premiums
is he practicing yeah like you know
tenet to an extent yeah why I want to
know is do really like like he doesn't
pray five times a day but he doesn't eat
pork right so he's like culturally he
drinks but like his dad runs the mosque
in San Jose and you know it so even
people who are like culture who aren't
incredibly devout are into this if he
had the option he would prefer how all
financing over not if it was convenient
and he's like the problem with all the
existing options they're not convenient
they're not easy to use and they're very
high premiums he's like if these guys
did it conveniently I think this could
be big so he's gonna talk to him we'll
see
like I'm not a practicing anymore are
you guys Catholic you're Catholic for
sure right do you eat meat on Friday I'm
let me to I went to an all-boys Catholic
High School I don't practice anymore but
that's another thing I don't eat meat
during Lent on Friday so I try not to so
it's kind of it sounds like that's what
it's kind of like we're it's like people
it's a spectrum it's a you prefer it but
not yeah you preferred especially if
it's convenient for you you'd you'd you
know the way Henry just said that a lot
of guilt they're like yeah I should but
I don't
so there's you know if you can make it
where people do what they want to do
without lifting a finger then they'll do
it you know that's great that's pretty
cool I like that I like that thing or I
like that angle of finding cuz I don't
know anything about Muslim culture I
don't know anything about Hindu culture
which is you where you're from you I
don't know you probably don't know too
much about Catholic yeah it's kind of a
way to like look at how other religions
do things right another thing that we
should talk about not today because I
don't think we know what we're talking
about we definitely don't yet is
building things on top of banks I think
that's super interesting what do you
mean by that so like what simple did and
like what the what's the name of this
company man's oh man spell it ma n zi l
manzil okay kind of like what manzil did
a building a building a front-end on top
of someone else's back-end right which
is the bank I think that that's really
interesting
simple calm is my card I didn't know
they did this at first this is kind of
what dropshipping is so where you build
the layer that says I'm going
get the customer to a landing page and
they buy yeah but it's just gonna place
an order with this other manufacturer
and they'll ship it directly it's super
effective I like that with banks because
like simple they did this I mean it's
it's a little different the card is all
white and it's a branding like looking
yeah and their app is really good and so
it's kind of interesting I think this is
kind of what Breck's is doing right
totally work hard yeah they're layered
on top of MasterCard I love these things
I really like that let's talk about uh
how many minutes are we in we're we're
about an hour in okay you want to we can
answer some questions and what you want
to do let's do one of these fun ones so
let's do the rebranding words said this
was in the hustle hustle trends trends
hustle Facebook group which is like a
source for entertainment and gold which
go to trends CO and sign up and if you
use the phrase million million you'll
get Ranchos /my I believe that's it is
it
is it / million or it's a promo code
both both will work at Ko / million or
Transco you guys have this thing where
you can sign up for a dollar which is
pretty dope yeah it's working girl love
it I love it okay so so so somebody the
group the key scroll of I don't remember
if I have their name should have their
name too yeah there you go okay we don't
have the name
we should which might and will you
finally the name of the guy who wrote
this because I want to give him credit
so somebody was just talking about like
hey isn't it funny how people just
rebrand stuff and like give it a whole
new meaning so he's talking about msg
he's like Oh MSG which was like got this
really bad reputation for being a food
out of a of whatever and just rebranded
as umami and now it's just like foodie
word that like is good and somebody came
into the the comments with like a bunch
of really funny ones you want to know
another food one aioli aioli mayonnaise
mayonnaise has a little garlic flavoring
look it up look it up hey only is
flavored mayonnaise look up
ao Lee versus Google is aioli mayonnaise
I've been telling you hey Olli is
mayonnaise but there's like way more you
have to do it in a separate tab you
can't you can't do this because we have
to over here he's right there what's the
answer say it says it right there what's
the top result
what's it say is a only any different
than mayonnaise am i off alright Henry
wins okay it's not it's not exactly Mayo
but I like the intent all right so let's
go back to the dock yeah I love it
so so this guy had a bunch of them for
business which I like so ordinary you
know when you skip you know I don't know
I'm like this I skipped breakfast for
years because I'm just lazy it didn't
wake up early enough and now it's
intermittent fasting it's like this
health trend it's like oh I'm fasting
till me and it's like yeah you skip
breakfast okay Marlin Marlin was the
original post and then who posted all
these comments and it's a Logan Jeffrey
J Logan had a bunch of them that were
fire that I liked that's the reason I
put it on here okay so when you just
create your job because you want to
travel now that's called dispersed
retirements which I like when you're a
grossly under employed writer or
marketer now you're a digital nomad
because you have to go live in some low
cost area or a coach when you just like
to eat beef and cheese because it's
delicious and now that's called the
carnivore diet or keto I call salami and
cheese
redneck charcuterie sleeping around
online dating I don't agree with all
these I'm just I'm relaying Logan's good
ones when you quit your shitty business
idea that was bad all along and everyone
told you it was bad it's called pivoting
I like that failing fast when you have a
fear of commitment and therefore do not
own anything and do not settle down
you're now practicing minimalism so
these are great and in general you know
funny [__] aside I think there's a lot
of power to this I think is a leader you
often have to rebrand stuff so that it's
more palatable to your team and or to
your customers packaging yeah you have
to frame things package them up in a
certain way we do this with our sushi
restaurant where we realized that if we
just described things better or
differently with with it with better
words people would buy more and we could
charge more because people wanted to
have sushi that was more sophisticated
so when we called it you know whatever
you know Atlantic salmon with
blah blah rather than just saying salmon
that was better or if we would create a
whole new word altogether and put a
little trademark next to it that was
even better than using common words
every once in a while I like there's
certain things that they use the
positive phrase and just generally
accept it I like to use like a word that
means the same thing but it's generally
regarded as a negative just to [__] with
people so for example instead of saying
like well we're gonna get the customer
to do this I couldn't get them to buy by
doing this or we're gonna influence them
by doing this I like to use the word
manipulate yeah let's manipulate I'm you
get him to do this like like words that
by definition work right just to kind of
what happens if we call it what it is
yeah so we're gonna manipulate up like
I'm gonna manipulate this person to like
you me like how you do that
well I'm should be nice and charming and
manipulate sort of influence with them
and I love to screw people or like when
political people say like well they have
an agenda like yeah well so look guys
I'm here to talk to you about my agenda
which is to do like right of course I
have an agenda I'm trying to get you to
do stuff like yeah you're you're
targeting like someone has a political
agenda yeah sure right yeah they should
have a political agenda I love you think
those words Henry if you scroll up for a
second so that's the end of this episode
thanks for listening tell your friends
make it all happen leave us a review we
like that give us the real talk in the
reviews because we read all of them and
we liked it or tweeted us Sam's got
12,000 Twitter followers now he has
surpassed me in the Twitter ring 11300
11300 counting so so he's winning great
all right we're out of here thank you
[Music]